China has been pretty much close to the
world for three years but restrictions
are now being relaxed and from the 8th
of January Beijing is reopening its
borders that means there will be no more
quarantine for people on arrival but as
China lifts restrictions some countries
are reintroducing them the U.S Italy
India Malaysia Taiwan South Korea and
Japan have all introduced mandatory
testing for anyone arriving from China
that's because they're worried about a
covered Surge and new variants but other
countries including Australia France and
the UK say they won't bring in extra
testing
a lot of people will be concerned about
the news coming out of China the sector
state for Health and Social care met
with the chief executive of the UK
Health Security Agency and the chief
medical officer this morning so it's
being taken incredibly seriously by the
government the key threat is any new
variant there's no evidence at this
point of a new variant from China a
variant that is not already prevalent
here in the UK but nevertheless we're
keeping the situation very much under
review
the data
possible to know exactly what's going on
in China for the last few weeks China
has been reporting around 5 000 cases a
day that's a significant drop from the
larger numbers in November and early
December but testing is limited and
officials are no longer reporting daily
cases so these numbers do not reflect
the true picture
we do know though that China has a very
large population with very low immunity
and Hospital admissions have been rising
rapidly and that is certainly why their
worries in Italy
every single country should look at
China and Chinese people traveling
abroad with particular attention because
the possibility of importing new strains
potentially with higher dangerous
potential with for the human health and
escaping the existing vaccine protection
in our countries is a possibility which
is a substantial I guess
EU Health officials have been meeting
but despite Italy's pleas there won't be
a coordinated response yet for now the
UK isn't making changes either but the
world is watching China very closely